when a legion stadium is at full
capacity there are 65 000
cooks in the kitchen to avoid spoiling
the broth the 2 billion
palace is featuring just a few elite
chefs chris matthews now joins us there
and he's going to give us a bit of a
taste good evening chris
well thank you very much john yeah this
thing is winding down a taste of
allegiance stadium
there are about 30 concessionaires
inside here really privileged to be
inside here
colin fukunaga is one of those with fuku
burger and colin thank you very much for
joining us
i'll tell you what it must have been so
exciting when you hear the phone call
saying hey you want to be part of this
legion stadium thing i couldn't believe
it i
i give uh all praise to levy and
and to the raiders uh being part of the
raiders family it's a huge honor
you know we started as a food truck and
to get to the to the legion stadium i
had no idea how that was going to happen
but we're so honored
it seems like it's also important to
have quality food at stadiums in today's
world right i think you know like
you know when we're approached i think
the uh the levy group had mentioned that
the fans really want to support local
brands
and they also want to have people that
really care about their food they don't
want
you know this you know nationwide chains
that just you know care about the bottom
line they want
they want these local vendors that have
passion about what they do
for a living you know and this burger
right here that you just got a shot of
this burger is a one of a kind you will
only be able to get this here inside of
legion stadium it's exclusive just
for the for the stadium
which means black and silver or silver
and black burger it's a homage to al
davis because he used to get
his favorite food was a mcdonald's
hamburger with
kfc uh coleslaw and you put it together
as a burger and if you
if you you know study up on what he used
to eat that's it's an homage to
the al davis all right well colin thank
you very much i appreciate you joining
us
once again here's the burger right here
john treach you will absolutely enjoy
this colin thank you
reporting live from allegiant stadium
taste of a legion is over unfortunately